all right and we are finally laughs I
just want a blank King for that there we
go the people under the bus and running
them over a few fishermen any and I
respect their respective welcome to the
I love I guess episode number 98 and
it's another glorious day we're back at
the round table or the more day
we've got apex legends in the future of
titanfall division 2 private beta versus
anthem demo PS 5 backward compatibility
and crackdown 3 multiplayer to discuss
so we are gonna get right into it so
let's introduce the four horsemen of
gaming don'ts original noise of realm
here at the round table my calls with
the cold most my brother from another
mother
the difficult game Conqueror and the
howl of the young man recovering from
the of my apex addictions I need to go
ahead and put myself in some kind of
rehab facility for this because that's
pretty bad
me and dizzy literally stayed up late
for in the morning I play does I gotta
go to bed I got I got I Opie in the
morning I'm dumb I gotta go you know how
I knew I was gonna get you at it it's
like overwatch up and I'm not gonna lie
the game is fight game is over
I mean apex Legends addiction I mean
thank god this game came out when there
was no games I had a review because
there would have been some gays put on
the back burner be like no that's that
day you got to sit over there and of
course we have our most technical gaming
Lord the solo gamer who lives for the
single player selfish experience and
also the sastra darkness mister offline
profile loominatee and
a patron of the iron bank mommy Lord
sovereign how're you doing sir
what's up guys can't resolve this what's
up you'll see the way you don't see the
wave I lay my bed and I put the mic over
my head I hang the laptop from the
ceiling you don't know like a phone
that's on speaker like I'm actually in
my car right placer so I actually played
almost all the things you think I
wouldn't play I got my poor Warren I
upgraded my little laptop game so I'm
just a nice little 10 60 on my laptop so
when we get to pax I'll be playing
crackdown and Forza horizon and all that
how do you play any of that right now I
just got it this week so I just trying
everything I enjoyed it I mean I enjoyed
the beginning parts of the division 1
and like everything else I fell off but
um man when I saw it I came pretty man
like the environments seemed they seemed
I don't know how you put it like lived
in they don't seem like Division one
felt like it was really kind of a lot of
the environments fork and layer these
this is
like it's snowing at night right they
expanded just a they just expanded like
the look of it everything look so much
more when you see it right didn't it
look exactly like what they showed it
III slander early in the intro can wait
so yeah that's pretty much better
answers anything else
um so once we get through intros we will
get at this patreon you know and of
course we have the Incredible Hulk of
this aka the XS gamer ooh the lord of
combat sports was a man of his
convictions demands nothing less than
that premium experience it is the leader
of the fraud alert movement ooh
beloved Lord King how you doing sir I'm
doing actually horrible man um if you
can't tell I've been crying all week um
I lost my best friend
um I wasn't going to talk about it I
wasn't even like make it a thing because
I don't I'm not one of these sympathy
mangas um I don't want a bunch of uh you
know hey King how you doing
uh none of that stuff um but been a
horrible week so with that said though I
it was like I was in a time warp
because apex drop I'm like be me hear
about this game being dropped and it was
like it felt surreal to me so when I
wanna pop it on I said you know this
this is that thing so um played that um
and I ordered the division cuz you know
Carl hit me up cuz we was talking and I
picked up the you know the premium
edition so you know so I got that this
is Nike in the mail real quick yo
tomorrow you know you get bigger and
I've been on the beta in the shadows
playing at that game so heavy and being
that I was in the shower
I was playing with a lot of randoms I
probably got like 20 new friends off of
that you know meeting up grouping up
doing things and even though I did play
it at e3 I'm and got a chance to play at
a fan fest I know exactly what we were
getting but to actually have it in my
house so I can dissect it and say
exactly what was different from part one
I really think that's how you do a thing
we're gonna talk about the later but um
no joke and that apex the gun feel I was
like yeah they milled it so that's what
i've been playing i've been playing you
know division and apex back and forth
everybody rocket and of course we have
the lord of the cooperative experience
and gaming ninja himself the shinobi
lore kognito
spread never illness in the realm of the
ILP not telling you what you want to
hear but what you need to hear so yes a
mature man blazing that division to beta
I missed the crackdown 3 Tech Vader well
I think I had a specific window so I'm
gonna catch it actually after the
podcast because they have another window
right after so I was doing that and then
throwing it back on a switch shout-out
to my Manny box I play a shadow - a day
it was bad different from the arcade Oh
money
one was like its own thing but I
actually like to Genesis they showed
upgrade they did this comparison I saw
this guy on YouTube that doesn't he does
like old arcade conversions that never
really was the same and that is it's
like you said its own complete entity
way they did it is could you know they
couldn't do Shadow Dance yeah yeah ok
you know what is the Ark if you look ok
what he got the stink walk in the ark
yeah walk in the arcade I always felt a
way for graphically they look better but
he ain't look minja right yeah he was
mad but that dog this is those races
yeah that's like I had tweeted it was
like they say no cheetah but it's like I
got epoxies with the last this week and
I saw the graph I don't know who did
that graph a graphic guy you throw like
I thought you know you know why cuz it's
not at all what you expect it's not not
at all what you expect out out whoa whoa
ow
the Lord cat daddy fat stacks oh wow him
brother our super chat losing a loved
one is hard but those great memories
will let your friend live on Shirdi
brother you know saying absolutely first
of all thank you for your kindness king
is going through it you have no idea yo
I'm so happy that he even made the
podcast I know the type of week he's
having and for you guys even give your
condolences to his friend and offering
it really means a lot thank you so much
that was that was don't thank you okay
I really appreciate it thank you so much
you've always been a super supportive
habit really means a lot
you have no idea yeah now me so yes
doing the Shadow Dance a comparison
having fun with that and then um I think
yeah I was actually addict I touched
Apex legends we'll get into that but uh
we will definitely I just visualize like
you know that dude in the bathroom
cleaning up cleaning up the stalls with
love that means king of statues is
coming if you also notice if you look up
at the top you see all those army bowls
and those Disney infinity
because I unpacked those dudes I had a
hope bro I got every last one of them so
I'd have room in there I'm gonna do a
room tour and all that other stuff and
um all these cabinets right here I'm no
they gonna be for sale because I just
realize yeah yeah trust me is a 4k 60
frames per second experience but it's
dual camera so I'm learning on the fly
guys and I was gonna do a combat talk
yesterday oh let me get to that real
quick I was on a combat talk yesterday
Devante tank Davis was supposed to fight
and Marez the ANA Marez was diagnosed
with a detached retina that fight did
not happen so I didn't do a combat talk
because he's fighting Hulu Lewis and he
not Hugo out in the first round
um he who came up to weight classes just
javante saying Dave his knock them out
in spectacular fashion um it was it was
an OK fight it wasn't something that
anybody really you know how did you know
check out but I'm really anticipating of
this UFC card I want to try try to get
to watch that with Cognito and team rome
but um yeah that's probably be my next
combat saw stuff Saab should we talk
about it we get a little bit about I
missed III actually fell asleep before
the damn main event but you sorta made
of it though
I watched a little bit of it this
morning oh let me just break it down man
I mean listen relax yourself
you know I'm saying we all know this
this man is a twilight of his career you
know everyone was predicting a morning
like Israel Alesana he's that guy like
he I'm saying there's no doubt about it
they came out you know say it first Rock
kind of feel each other but I gotta give
Israel his day he was styling like you
know he was calm he was ready
for the moment and I in the beginning I
my he caught Edison one time and you
know the chin when you older to Chile
low chanting suspect yeah I don't look
good it don't look good but Dennis yeah
he showed how to climb back he was
waving on him he was charged on with the
heads like for if you're an assassin
affair right now ii wanted to give you
at area on you my dad - dude i remember
so he had the young boy stumbling on his
back it was late so everybody's like cuz
if we round fight because he got to the
main event but he's ahead about contract
was on the three ground so when he got
to the dark joint you know i'm saying i
go for like israel was just more active
right now there was one moment go around
to our kind of talk about where he
caught israel had him up against the
fence vintage and descent this dude was
about to be out in my opinion he was
about to be out in with the flying
because you knows when super got you if
you're coming yeah this kid is such a
fan and studies anderson so well you of
the soil even know what he saw he moved
at the movies so cuz to me was the bull
in this that not yeah they both stepped
up for the main event cuz we don't rob
whitaker got hurt man it was the best
possible I'll go cuz I won't get my
legend I need to see a Roy Jones with
his feet crossed II know you know my
alleges always have a tendency to grow
in their primes that they don't know how
to lose well so like horribly these guys
were superior egos exactly and it's like
it did I love that it was if he's gonna
lose is he gonna pass the torch to pass
to this kid because this kid got so much
respect for the game so much respect for
him he could see what you brought tears
to his eyes they hugged it like it was
that's why I love MMA it was vintage
respect so if anybody's gonna pass it to
is this kid we're gonna see what's going
on but yet it was late man it was a
little quick what what is this thing
that Connor was talking about that that
Kelvin Gaston looks sick as well like
nah cuz Kevin gasoline running around
with a fake Bell on his chest
oh that but he when he said also that
Kelvin looked like he was sick as well
like there was something on his face or
something it was last minute what
happened - um probably was serious very
serious surgery the whole bit so you
know you know it sucked because we did
want to see that he's the champion here
in Goa Kelvin is coming you never say I
would it was just a great middleweight
tournament that just got interrupted at
the end you know me so you know it is
what it is we go see what's been
happening if Karma's going wait you know
I'm saying and obviously I um Israel's
won't get to shine well so we all you
know what happens to Kelvin around with
like it's the Tory Lanez it is work so I
just love that finally someone went at
that narrative the way they needed to
yeah hello to the police bills moment we
got good that the Lords of the iron fake
time but we got now I'm okay daddy big
statue something man okay he's at the
top of the heap baby
she who said I listened to the podcast
later have a good podcast Lord he said
I'm always here for that combat talk
that's what's up Thank You Lora
so once again yeah we push patreon back
to this week because of having Derrick
Lewis on last week so definitely now
it's time to give up Big Ups to all our
supporters again thank you everybody for
always being there so let's get through
these names so to start off gonna go
with mr. Xavier Medina thank you so much
for support brother you don't like it
hey man you need to put that in the
patreon from now on we know real man's
real second but at least a bit Lord
whiskey himself Cory lighting out there
y'all is everybody you just go for me to
Cory then of course the PlayStation brah
thank you for my friend salute to the
brah we will see you soon and then
followed by Lord Kareem H comm pastors
thank you so much for the support so
little cream eggs baby of stuff but that
was good and a man with the best image
on the internet pants down me slow-mo
back slow that's the guy need to change
ever needs to always stay the same next
we have Lord Kris Williams aka Lord fast
back 67 as Mac in the win
followed by Lord Ahmed Hernandez
thank you for the support much
appreciated salut I'm a brother thank
you thank you so much now we have two
new patrons to the realm so oh you so
long wait first off we have Lord John
love sound like an R&B sing
vagabond oh okay look back upon the old
vagabond oh that's my guy that's a
certain followed by Lord sincere Kent on
another hot name thank you so much for
the support appreciate it
followed by the Lord of back compat and
Project X cloud Lord just know we're
heirs together together still teaching
the competition to get it together the
Great Wall and stealth town finest baby
that's a night guy right there followed
by Lord Ricky Moore jr. aka Lord two's
gaming thank you so much for TV rocket
what is heavy
I salute oohs then of course the first
patron ever Lord Michael ooh go monkey
punch thank you so much person to chat
every on the real punch could we please
get this up up g together right now
we're playing in the days where he's
living in Caddyshack sand bull craps
let's get it together and we got nice
houses and nice whips and stuff now
we're moving at 60 friends yeah I know
the death knell but you see all right
now we got Lord Sammy Prescott thank you
so much Sam Garity solo prestigious name
trust God the next three names are just
this LP family of course we got Lord J
Farnes neutral fire he got right now and
of course if if
you want anything and everything to do
with division to check out the king of
the stream team though it's now don't
know all weekend long can dreaming after
ILP so if anybody have a stay in
Division two yet please get in there
he's going hard and screaming on the
Isle pita twitch channel so salute to
Laura PD mmm and he's followed by family
from cradle to the grave Lord Coe
ambered aka loaded pixels Colbert uh
family family baby day one baby sounds
great of course our brothers from across
the pond Lord death singer himself wave
changed you put the tune down with the
Colossus you need ever know that pop G
need to get out there and of course last
but not least Lord cat daddy fats dad
oh yes the Lord has every color way ever
imagined with the call yeah we gotta
give cat dad he's the leader of getting
addict to get that drink daddy movement
that's coming soon we forget
we ain't no no forget that now he's gone
it's going down to for sure let's do it
those down though right so let's get
into these giveaways really quickly so
let's start off with this $10 gift card
giveaway we need that we need
a little blue DJ we needed easier goby
hologram yeah we need we need transition
music for all this mu I lords DJ Leslie
already set his rig let's go the winner
of the $10 gift card giveaway Oh like an
industry person like Bill still were
like oftentimes you know you wouldn't
expect him like whatever to pay it
forward he's never come up because you
know right away he's gonna take them by
that $20 skin you just make sure you
give my cut death you know how it goes
alright last but not least the teespring
giveaway who would that sway oh the
winner of the teespring giveaway for
February 2019
amen maybe favorite coach that's nicer
me what you want to do what you do
except that could always be honest once
again thank you guys for the support you
appreciated like you have no idea this
is always great to have especially
getting new people and that's our goal
just to keep giving you content that you
want to see so thank you you know I ran
the champion I've seen a bottle
you know premium like that's that for
fourth of July super occasion you know
350 years old or some type of work
in and what he's failing to tell you
it's like 600 alcohol percentage you
will drink it you will turn into Lord
fireball we don't need you to have a
little fireball situation by two rows
right there that's a cheese stack you
Indian so we got let's get it to this
pole last week's poll results are in and
the people have spoken
in regards to the recent controversy
regarding Metro Exodus move from steam
and now to the epic storefront do you
consider this latest exclusive deal by
epic just another competitive move the
winner with 39% of the three-way vote
was the yes devs make more money and
consumer gets game for cheaper group
coming in at a razor close second place
at 36% was the PC gamers are finally
getting a taste of that console war
smoke last place at 25 percent of the
vote was no they are just buying being
epic third-party timed exclusives
anti-consumer
group thanks to all the lords who voted
on last week's alt pulse Lord addict
what do you think about this I can't run
IOP I can't get my opinions on that's
good I am NOT able to talk about this
subject let me tell you something I
think is genius I think you strike while
the iron is hot I think you go in while
you got the hot game right now apex is
showing you there about the yank that
rug from under your feet so you better
eat while you can brother everybody you
can get onto your team right now because
y'all running out of steam no pun
intended I like that one I like that how
you feel about that song for G that you
feel them
stop whining and stop crying and go
download the damn epic
but snob the quality is not up to snuff
once again I don't care if it takes two
days to download the game once it's
downloaded is downloaded say it again
that's beyond excited a I was
downloading uh cross-buy games on from
the Xbox Store Xbox tour is just it
doesn't download nearly as fast as it
does on Steam but once it was downloaded
that's that myself from iron Lords
podcast I approve that message yeah here
speaking with eats of spades bottles and
we got a lot to discuss big show so what
we're going to start off with apex
legend so we can break this up into
parts or we're gonna talk about first
the announcement you know I mean I've
talked to the game itself and then the
second part which will save or will be
the actual future of the titanfall
franchise so let's start off with just
Apex legends the announcements let's
bring it in
Lord addict what did you feel when you
saw this game have you played it well
actually you know you played it you know
sample what what are you feeling about
apex legends right well you can ask Lord
dizzy the night before you know we're
sitting out here in the road I was
playing I think that's playing Kingdom
Hearts but uh so see her grinding
because I'm trying to get you know ready
for content drops on Kingdom Hearts and
talking to Lord dizzy
and he's like yeah I don't think there's
gonna be Titans in it you guys Lord is a
I said immediately I'm not even staying
up for this [ __ ] now so you know what
I'll go ahead so I wanted to that was
like a first off they did some sliced up
they're like we have a trailer that's
gonna be a teaser and then we're gonna
have the actual reveal its well so I
showed up for the actual teaser and it
was literally just screenshots of the
map over and over again and I'm like
that is some slacking yes you were
pissed off so you know
comes up me Lord Cognito and Lord is you
all were in a party watching it
first off Lord kognito is very disgusted
whoa
why did they sit like the longer the
reveal trailer went on the more I was
like I'm about this life I'm about this
life I'm about this life and then you
know sadly I had to go to work but the
moment I got home that then I ended up
putting like 22 hours in the so just
like you feeling about it you've been
blazing you know by far but Wow cuz you
know it doesn't have that building stuff
like that's one of the things I don't
really like about for tonight I
understand it's what makes it so unique
but at the same time I'm like I don't
want to have to play Bob the Builder at
the end of every fortnight trying to
kill people I just want to shoot people
but you know this game has a good middle
ground you could actually revive people
in an epoch so you know I won a couple
games by describing banners running
through the map and then reviving my
teammates at the very end we just it's
crazy because in other battle Royales
besides there's one more there's another
one that lets you revive people but
another battle Royales usually if you
die within the first three or four
minutes the rest your team's gonna wipe
this is the restart though cut needle
what made the game win for me that
aspect right jumping jumping see like
when you said that okay okay my son saw
it and he saw it on the dashboard and he
said you know because I'm going through
it and he's like download that I seen
that so I said okay I clicked in and I
download it and when I downloaded it and
he went through the whole tutorial and
then it says when you're when your guy
dies you can pick up his banner you can
go to a recharging station and bring him
back to life that instantly changes the
engagement times people walk away from
the controller but your death kinda lit
man you got it actually with the nature
of battle royal right because first you
drop down the first couple of
interactions
you know it feels like you part of the
game you did so but this allows you to
come back it so it keeps your engagement
there keeps you with your teammates and
once he gets you up he brings you back
you know he MVP right now I've literally
seen the game and the only reason they
won is because of a well put in revive
like for like well when it comes to like
pudgy and stuff when you get into
situations where like one or two people
die like it's just pretty much like I'm
gonna stand my ground until I die or
they die right because at the end of the
day your peoples ain't there you you
kind of wanting to die at that point
this it's like okay to my people were
down can I get their banners and boat
can I get away and there's been a couple
of times where I've literally was like
okay I can't take on three people so III
you know I do some ninja stuff grabbed
by teammates banners they just run like
run away okay to get them back fight
another day and I'll meet those same
people I've literally lost battles to
people at the beginning got my people
back up and then beat them to win the
game at the end Wow
you see that has a whole new different
dynamic and it's never easy like when
you're reviving somebody you're exposed
completely okay so in the reward thing
you don't know whether you should do it
or not you know I take that out and just
start you know go for the next rise you
know like I like the mobility of the
game nobody's been talking about the
mobility of the wall running cog I know
titanfall universe head yeah yeah I feel
what you're saying right but at the same
thing first day and you know what that
goes into that goes into the second half
of this got out of a magazine right so
but this makes it completely unique that
slide and aspect of it and then you pick
up speed you can get the hell out of
there I was
shut up and I got the hell out of it by
sliding down there's been a couple of
times where I've slid down a hill and
they thought I just left like what and
all I did was slide downhill a little
bit and hid behind a rock and so they
forgot I was there shot gonna kill them
and mantling the mantling feels really
good and you can actually get pretty
even mantle on some things that you
probably didn't think you could so there
were a couple of ledges out like there's
no way I'm getting two that would do it
now would get to it so it seems like
they sort of increase the range for that
to allow for the for the mobility to be
like a little more expanded and in some
instances I kind of felt however I don't
want to say it kind of like mirrors edge
a little bit um so I guess they did try
to do that sort of stuff to try to make
up for the fact they don't have the wall
running and that you know and adding
that dimension to it but I think the
movement is great I think and it's in
its limiting enough
we're like the the tenants of battle
royale still sort of fit where if you
add the wall running in there and feel
cooler duteous yeah and the best thing I
love about it like I think is normally
in being battle royale games choil Tom
Oh Tom oh no smell dough you go getting
a shirt leggings you know you believe in
man you get a shirt redemption green one
so you can stand in front of the green
screen and just disappear completely
because your arms will be sticking out
in the logo the thing I love the most
about this game is in other battle
Royales like when you get to like the
last like 20 people you know you'll have
a squad that has three people a squad
that has two you rarely get to a point
where everyone's still there and this
game it's like you
always know there's gonna be three why
almost every encounter
you killed sued use okay where's the
third where's the third words the third
like like you actually prefer that
because you say you know I don't I just
go because in pub G they wear solos and
duo's can be in quads and stuff you
always had that part where you don't
know how many people's there yeah that
unknown variable is aggravating but
across a group you know it's three yeah
because where they added that as my
chances are if you didn't pick up
someone's there's very few scenarios
where you don't get their banner so
there's always gonna be sets of three
I've had a couple times where I couldn't
get the better cuz the fight lasted long
enough cuz the banner only stays on
first there's certain amount of time but
nine times out of ten if you didn't get
the banner you died with them you don't
wanna like I like the jump boss thing
like I'm the boss we jumping and then a
do can do the Deaf thing I'd be like I'm
breaking off I don't I don't think that
they're going to imply a pay2win aspect
in this because it's reasonable response
very anti all that [ __ ] why he says the
banner stays there for 90 seconds
yeah 90 seconds but that's enough time
to get stuff like if it's like I said
nine times out of ten if you don't get
that banner the whole team died for the
last you know three or four squads like
there's a good chance what about art
direction don't like it's like it's so
many aspects that I just he gets other
see first it's like it's a marriage the
marriage has been and this is what's the
mobile I love the people do yeah because
the art direction and a gunplay but the
art direction is not getting enough
praise because in this day and age where
you have such personalities and
characters they got it right they did
their research they looked at overwatch
they looked at
paddling's and I mean they said you know
what we need to have some type of
charisma to the characters they did
phenomenal job there yes anything is
what they didn't do that overwatch does
is that overwatch specific characters
have specific counters for other
characters that's not case here here you
eat one has their own sort of power and
you can use it to your advantage
depending on your situation but it's
never feels like you have only one way
out of a situation yeah I like the track
of do did yesterday yeah the funny thing
about this game is running is always it
off the chick with the smoke because
like what was funny is like you just
shoot smoke around you and it's it's
like those old movies where they throw
that little smoke bomb and they
disappear with the smokes got like the
whole team gone when that smokes gone
like yeah you so many times like things
will go south with me dizzy will be
playing I'm like okay this is too much
overall things you just you with it
honestly again I get I always fall off
of this type of game but I was really
impressed when I it's it's a very
complete product which you necessarily
expect from battle Royals today I mean
like pugsy still getting fixed like you
know it sort of takes the fortnight
model and eliminates what I personally
don't like a lot more night which is the
building yeah you walk that line that
cartoony line where it's stylized in
terms of art style but it's not
straight-up cartoony like fortnight yeah
and I just think it takes the best
aspects of a battle royal and and sort
of expands on it in its own way it's
really like honestly like it's the most
complete battle royal out there I think
and it's and the onboarding is fairly
easy because it's more in the fortnight
style like it's it's hard for somebody
to jump into something like pub G or
Daisy now that would look off of those
armor mods like was it you know
cremation any office already yeah I know
someone that drunk shout out the clown
he dropped $30 in this dizzy last night
I was talking he's like yeah he popped
up Mirage you know that's the first time
I've ever seen him use him I'm like
would you get him he's like a drug to
you death the bed Michael chair thank
you God the only thing I don't like
about the game I'm kognito said during
the stream is I think eight people was
two less to launch this with because
like I do feel like none of their
Ultimates are really like besides you
know maybe the show dudes artillery none
of them are really like useful useful
like you got the a you know I'm
completely on the other opposite end
when it comes to right
I don't pursue pers useful at all like
that I think I think they felt that they
want to defeat it is out like they
wanted to do you know how fourth leg
does releases every week yeah keep the
engagement up so when they reveal a new
character that you're begging for it
you're looking for it they're
anticipating it
that's what they're trying to do there
what I mean to see is if they do a
fortnight does which which story like I
know I talked about this a long time ago
the story and I um there's recently uh
we will I worked on an editing an
article where that specific thing is
mentioned as well where it's like well
you know when you create narrative in a
game that doesn't necessarily you don't
expect to have it in the engagement for
people who are playing that game all the
time it's crazy because also you giving
them a reason for for the things that
are happening in the game some sort of
however whatever a surface level it is
it's still something to keep that
creates narrative in this world and I
think I think this games more of an
arena shooter than about a role yeah
like it was like it because of the speed
you'll be sitting there what I love like
is just the immersion that this game
games like you'll be sitting there it's
like you know you're playing is yourself
but you're really playing his race right
the announcers say I've literally one
time I had the I was the robot I
keep forgetting their names but I was
the robot and they're like the the
champion we have a new champion and then
the robot was like let's look for the
champion or something like that someone
else said that and then it's like 10
seconds later they said the champion has
been eliminated
robot said well that was fast yeah
comment on what's going on like if
you're not in the circle when a new
circle is formed they will say that
they're like we're not too far we're not
in this circle we're far away from the
circle they're always reminding the
player what's going on so in deluding
you forget that you got to be in the
circle yeah
it's that's the aspect that kind of you
forget about like in pub gee I'm always
calm I was always cognizant over the
circle to be honest with you man like I
ain't never really I don't think it's a
fortnight killer I think that fortnight
is more of a casual eyes game you know
all the little kids and stuff they're
gonna still play for Andrew but all the
streamers and all the people that
actually can count to 10 bro that was a
blow boom
we know that for tonight plays in
counting time I don't know I don't know
if they ever try to do something with
this game where they put it on portable
they put it on phones aside that's ever
been to dethroning for missing and
nobody said it yet is the fact that you
can play this game without a headset
yeah that's the game and what the funny
thing is though actually like if they
ping an equipment or something it will
tell you what equipment it's their
opinion they just know you there's
something interesting revolutionary late
yes everyone's gonna have to bite that
system now like they they've set a trend
with them let me get into this violence
all right let me start up look full
disclosure like yo I'm done with Battle
Royale y'all are like I just started
yes it I get it like it is you know what
it is cake is lame it's the new mumble
rap of gaming every publisher bitin
transman like that's popping like this
what this is how we can't industry like
it's better paddle is like here's the
thing I get in new corporate blue box
monetization is leading the sales chart
you don't say you know the only batter
Roy I love we all know was up what pub G
was based on realism you know but they
update was everything engine updating
was the worst you know I'm saying now I
wouldn't say pub G fail because still
success but it's been lapped by
everything like everything's laughed at
fortnight black i'ma give credit want
you guys to do put our IP pub Jean
anthem the wind is your destiny to die
[ __ ] that's what I meant listen at the
end of day I'm gonna give credit where
credit is due
wait this game is next level in that
genre that the voice chat is late squad
gameplay you don't say again I'm in my
feelings always because when I heard
this announcement you know me dizzy
attic in a chat so I'm like oh this
could be titanfall you know say like and
they said before they said there's no
Titans or wall running I was like this
once they said no wall running I'm sorry
no Titans the engine will blow up so I
gave them a pad
I like they no one can do that 60 Titans
ready to write like we're not at that
but that we ate that generation of
console yet I'm like that is a Titan
force it's in their universe so but not
a pilot so all I'm saying is I
understand the logic descended these
dudes are not
pilots right but again in my opinion
they set a trend when you play titanfall
that wall running and bouncing from side
to side that was the greatest thing I've
ever seen as far as traversal in the
first-person game so for me to not have
that I'm a feel away now I get the logic
behind it these guys are not pilots this
is just the universe cool I get it it's
just I'm just saying it would have been
in my opinion the greatest battle ever
if they really enjoyed I think that you
have to thank apex legends for titanfall
3 now because we gonna get to that we
gonna get to that I know where you go
you go get to that listen at the end of
the day we'll give credit where credit's
due my peoples that respawn they nailed
it they killed it it's just like King
said it's like overwatch Knight had a
baby you know I'm saying cuz you got the
squad aspect and I'm saying you got the
easy to play you know I'm saying and
then they got this arm the whole voice
chat system all that next level and a
splash of a little titanfall or it's
just not for me like I'm not gonna be
rocking this but I know y'all loving it
I know y'all gonna get it in now let's
get to adequate Atticus talking about
which is the hole that the future of
titanfall so added I'm gonna give it to
you you basically saying that because of
Apex I feel we go in at titanfall game
that's what you're going
I feel like if this game when it came
out they I felt like if this game would
flop they would after the Star Wars game
they might have just shut the whole
studio down like because titanfall 2 did
so bad I feel like because of this game
and how well it's doing epics EA school
bell okay they just made us a lot of
money just let them make the damn game
that's what I thought when I first heard
about this game I said ok this is how
they justify making titanfall 3 with a
campaign and everything they're gonna
make boatloads of money with this game
and then EA can't look at them and say
okay well we're not making enough money
we can't afford to give you titanfall 3
the way you would want to make it so I'm
thinking this is what's gonna make you
know this is the moneymaker this is the
moneymaker so you can make the other
games that you actually want to make
that's for 3 becomes
a day yeah yeah thing came out and said
that there's going to be news on
titanfall in the few gonna have time for
something at the end of this year later
a battle royale
we're titanfall I don't remember I said
that I said it I want y'all to remember
that go back and say I'm the Prophet as
we could see some of these characters go
into titanfall 3 - must we no I don't
think so I think they stay separate oh
they're building up the universe for a
reason yeah but I also feel that being
that you don't have no Titans you don't
have no wall running you're gonna get
that when you get the Battle Royale for
titanfall listen EA is at a point right
now where they're trying to get the
engagement level of CC right now the
industry has turned C Cognito doesn't
like the fact that mumble Ralph it's
turning into mumble right right but he's
missing the actual reason behind the
whole mumble rep its engagement you know
you're right you're right absolutely
right gonna make more money with you in
there every day and all timing skins and
you do absolutely right and I understand
the game it to me that's why I said this
is mama rap I understand why you say
enough and over our heartbeat you don't
saying everybody's doing it I mean I
like to like it and I think you missing
it right this spin the lyrics in this
game when you pick them see my whole
thing was what is gonna feel like
because I played the Call of Duty and it
was duty right so I was the comes didn't
feel right it felt like Call of Duty
felt like light the guns felt like it
didn't have that gravitas to it when I
shot these guns you know it's got a lot
to every gun mm-hmm and it and every gun
felt different so it gave it gravitas to
that then
started looking at the charm of the game
and we cut a win sovereign did say the
mantling up because I thought I couldn't
make that jump and I made us mumble
rabi's be hotdog it would be different
if they came and see a lot of bad
Aurora's feel like they they sort of
home they pigeonhole their game into a
battle royal it's obvious from apex
legends that they built it from the
ground up looking at what makes
titanfall strong parts of it not
everything right and then how they can
adjust that to the Battle Royale genre
like it's not pigeon holed at all and
you can see that by like the
improvements they've made to the things
like the pinging and stuff like that and
the way the movement works in the game
it just it feels like a politic like no
other battle royal it's like they have
like freed like creep in a room and
they're like okay what is pudgy
fortnight do good okay let's put a
harder piece of paper what's good ways
to improve that kind of formula put them
all in another piece of paper what is
what does titanfall do well put all that
the piece of papers like now let's put
all three of the papers together Mooney
downloaded this free game I use looking
around like you like you stole something
okay download anthem you look like I
think you need to pay for that joint for
free I'm still very all my I believe
that they dropped apex to get all that
heat I mean again I mean they couldn't
they could had planned for that right
the game had to be ready if it wasn't
ready you know this this is sudden let's
talk about that let's talk about that
cuz that's my issue me car boss who's
been going at it me and Izzy been going
everybody in the job my phone yesterday
young
room let's talk some controversy let's
talk about that my beloved titanfall
rest in peace you know I'm saying but I
don't recipes but you know and some
Jason Schreyer reporting because uh
Monday was at Monday the fourth that's
when we got apex legends was first
announced at the press event right so
then you boy the producer from respawn
came out he told Eurogamer he said the
world thinks we're making titanfall and
we're not this is what we're making so
it's like you know we're gonna truck try
and convince the skeptical audience so
that's why they kind of like stealth
dropped it you know and I'm saying so
this way there's no marketing plan you
just jump in and let them play I respect
that and I'm saying so people don't get
a chance to like tear it apart cuz let's
be honest once people hear EA you know
and you know it's a tendency to trying
to go in so the only thing is it's like
okay it was a surprise that they saying
that they drop trying for three I mean
it wasn't happening because we know
Schreyer charges rather we know just
Gordon they had reported already that
time four three been in development
since fall of 2017 so at that time
everybody was like what you mean he
wasn't making tagging for you don't say
it was just a surprise so that was when
Masada I was in I was like okay cuz
multiple sources have reported so then
come and I'll say hey make no sense to
me
so alright cool and without regards to
how you feel Jason Schreyer be on point
with his report no saying so then we
fast forward now was a Tuesday February
5th and then we got the EA earnings call
right and all of a sudden narrative
switches my boy Vince Zampella come out
we make a tweet apex was all our idea
this had nothing to do with EA
you know understand alright alright and
then he shouts out you know I want to
shout out Game Informer because again on
that same earnings call your boy what's
up way that we met our Matic um Andrew
Wilson from the CEO of omean we met him
at the yeah he comes out he's like oh no
no we there's gonna be one more
titanfall game coming out this year you
know and it's not a traditional
titanfall game and like all of a sudden
gear like it did it's like oh it's gonna
be a premium game launch this year new
twist on the China for universe more to
come later
so again king the always
we strolled Quanah mr. koala sound
suspect to me in this way like there's
no doubt in my mind this confirmed by
many legal shout out the whole many
financial gaming experts that the timing
of this release is another example EA
trying to force this in conjunction with
a fiscal calendar year you know say cuz
right now birds call here come the
release date you know say so it's just
like last time to me like they they
stacking like the same way they stack
battlefield attire for two they stacking
again I get it from a funny
I know what you're gonna say they choke
their own games out financial gain cuz
you want to put it in your fiscal year I
get it you gonna make that bread but we
seen what happened a time for long-term
you know say so the meat is just a bad
bad move yeah okay I mean one more last
point song cuz I gotta get this all like
here's the thing my final points look
like it's a huge mistake to launch apex
this close to Anthem apex is a monster
right now they got ten million three
days million reasons not the bar ten
million people let me tell you something
a lot to say
the anthem thing is um and imma have to
hit this on you guys out there you guys
out there that's sitting there talking
about is the hottest greatest sliced
bread crap it's a lot of you guys out
there yelling at this stuff from the
rooftops and I'm thinking it's coming
from a different place I'm thinking it's
coming from a place of destiny is too
far ahead for you so you can't jump us
our destiny to get that done and all you
you felt soured or you felt turned off
by something and I think the intentions
is wrong right so they see it and this
is gonna go into demo versus demo but
they saw the reaction of it there's a
too volatile of a reaction so when
you're looking at apex being dropped
apex is being dropped to put that fire
out because they like let's go on yeah
but a rock in the back and to get that
earnest this is your point to to get
those earnings up they're gonna have to
get these engagements in right and if
they look there something's - it's
taking a negative hit you says the 10%
loss maybe they saw people are canceling
a pre-orders right shout out the kids
move so um when you start looking at
people cancelling pre-orders you saying
okay so listen fire it off Apex without
little talking without anything anyway
it's a smash smash I think that will
happen you know obviously I will never
know this but I think they're like okay
like we're getting destroyed in the
media right now none of a debate was a
disaster
regardless that you want to put it
regardless the gameplay some people even
get a play that the closed one I feel
like they're like what can we do to make
the conversation not about anthem that's
right all right they could say that they
could save a patient's ready but the
thing is we got a bit like this apex
billion development just can't just pop
up the game you know I'm saying I don't
know let me just finish mom it could
have been done months ago never just
went for Ansan to be done but they
probably put the premium game in in
front of the audience and it was betting
heavy on this premium game everybody
look and worse we heard about anthem
since this came out and here's my point
exactly like you know how a digital
foundry is molding me just generation
right absolutely here's the thing apex
is a monster right now 10 million uses
in three days like the success even God
you know what's go for night a little
shook you know I'm saying because they
pulled up like regards to my feeling
about not like a game with free-to-play
or whatever it's a phenom it doesn't
bode well for anthem releasing in two
weeks on the 22nd I'm not saying it was
voting one for anthem for anthem being
released today I'm not saying it gonna
flop like Tiger for two you know I'm
saying but it definitely had the
potential this thing either potentially
be some biggest format and here's the
thing that everybody forgetting you know
I'm saying like yo the elephant in the
room battlefield 5 has a battle
you're supposed to drop in March Elsie
fire school who's copping fire saw me
and and then Andrew Wilson came out and
said that he felt that the game didn't
do as well as it could have because the
battle royal wasn't ready they just
threw battlefield in the bushes like
they they just crapped on their own
release window they put it too close to
anthem battlefield five is a dub now
nobody's paying for that what ain't
Texas free you know you know CEOs and
dudes in the boardroom they was on line
with this and EA had to put the fire out
okay if if I don't fix this this hole in
this [ __ ] I'll lose my job I'll share
about what game the problem with EA for
a minute alone
people fifteen million dollar sign up
bonus Harry there's been too much
seepage of the boardroom
into the development room and it's just
what's been happening with them for a
long time any that responds like you
ain't messing with my [ __ ]
listen at the end of the day you know
saying battlefield fives in the bushes
anthems too close and then back to the
time for thing what is this mean we
getting a new twist and spin on the
titanfall it's gonna be something
monetized it's gonna be a premium this
is not free to play like so I I love
titanfall titanfall I enjoy titanfall 1
I enjoy too little less than one but I
enjoy a pecs way better than the other
two to be completely honest with you if
I choose between titanfall 3 and apex I
pick apex every time I'm sorry he said
he already paid for anthem on PC I would
have not purchased a game apex is giving
me the refresher I need from destiny to
battlefield 5 firestorm battery while he
said it's coming out in May regardless
to if it's coming out Marsha if it's
coming out in May if you got the hottest
Royall out in the street that
free-to-play it's under your banner no
one's buying that paid DLC of a battle
royal they just want to battlefield a
long time ago before apex ever came I
thought battlefield misses opportunity
when they should have waited they should
have let the game cook right instead of
chasing Call of Duty don't stop stop
chasing them Yeah right and put the game
out with that mode with the battle
royale mode because it still seems like
you're chasing Call of Duty call the
duty already has that blackout mode
alright and these guys is loyal to that
Call of Duty stuff they're gonna be
there they're gonna get that stuff done
they said we're gonna throw the
single-player in the bushes you gambled
on a single-player and you lost so now
you back at it again you're back at
second place again and I understand EA's
point of view when the stock holdings
and everything starts to drop and then
you start to see the percentage in that
you check in the water and anthem is
taking a dip once digital found you put
the fat page out on your head you see
you start seeing those like the climax
coming out so you have to drop anthem
Nami Pitt's do they lose a small amount
of money from the development and you
know equal to the cost or they want to
lose quadruple that from their stocks
right lowering to the point where they
can't even get investors in their
company because all their games are
bombing yeah it's desperation or money
basically what it comes down to now is
what time for we actually getting to me
this whole thing still feel knee-jerk to
me cuz the gaming community let's be
real when we first heard the first day
that they weren't making a titanfall
everybody was tight you had
what's-his-face from the video games
awards Geoff Keighley was like yeah like
a lot of people point we do get we get a
titanfall with a single-player campaign
and with a really robust multiplayer at
some point we I'm not I'm not mad that
we're not getting in now like if we were
to get a time phone now we're talking
about three games in the span of one
generation but they said they've given
us Titus nutriskin
we got a super job we got stuff shout
out the R and L oh man Wow with the
super tax we supporting the mission of
iron Lords thrive hashtag greatness
thank you sir how much the page us love
brand l man thank you for the $23 super
chat wow this listen I just I just want
sorry afford to get a fair shake no and
that's that's the thing I get always
felt like each pawn has been the fall
guy in the middle like I do think we'll
see you titanfall but not anytime soon
and that's cooking before you do I think
respawn has just became like their
golden goose and I think that you know
unless someone else makes titanfall
three it's our goal has taken over
careful sorry for changed
and is just don't put my game out with a
bear release schedule again don't put it
next to court we don't put it next about
give my day if you will put on like I
think I think with Apex coming out it's
broad horizon and a lot of more people
have played this game I think your game
will actually get a lot more people
willing to try because they made a great
little cognitive finish the campaign
ever play solo it's amazing look I I
don't see any reason why they're not
using frostbite they need use for us by
its source engine has not been updated
now know how long it does good
listen the hell with that frostbite
because you know what paper mache
sometimes like a lot of stuff don't feel
real when you're looking at things that
don't look big money looking funny in a
light yeah tiny little photo apex is
like when you get Kyoto chances are it
was your stupidity not like not the game
itself like when I get killed I'm like
you know I missed those couple of shots
and that's all me it was at that like
cuz the one thing that we didn't really
you know give props to when it comes to
apex is the game runs like the it's one
of the best running Battle Royale
so let's respawn put they name is almost
fine it's an assault I'm not hating
listen I understand what you're talking
about
yeah you even you almost didn't even
watch the reality
they don't kill my game he don't want to
hear nothing you talking about because
the game that he was looking forward is
in the bushes for right now and it is a
direct culprit is a person he could
point the finger that's like they take
your finger each joint right though in
the bushes and put two showers of games
you despise work man this came
successful I can't listen this game is
gonna directly change titanfall the
torches out that show that's in your
background you need to get one that's on
a shield need to get your fire never
forget to create a bed never forget
that's nice let's move all your Lord
King what do we got in the date that
demo and made it Department out right
before we got to demos was talking all
this hot mess and couldn't log in right
so de forma pill
I'm not gonna front the the remix of the
demo please listen to my demo remix so
you played it you got in there and it
still was that disengagement that
separation the game suffers from
performance issues I mean you see it is
a red herring in the womb you understand
it then along came a spider and I told
you dudes last year that I don't know
where anthem fits but Division two said
confidently yo throw that bait out and
when the betta hit the streets it was
felt it was like the most concise step
to tool again and what I'm saying is how
to do a beta right do you do a beta
where you're not sure of the game where
you do a beta where you're confident
with your game and I'm looking at the
tale of two betas and I want to
understand where one went wrong and one
went right and what was wrong with one
and what was right with the other I want
to know your opinion because I know
everybody had got a chance to play both
betas and I wanna know where y'all stay
granting them are you paying to hire a
cool
let's get a dick thing that came back or
whatever maybe in the chat what's going
on man what's going on okay all right
okay and you know loading screen
simulator PowerPoint extraordinaire see
you guys me acted like you don't put me
on the blasts what format was he playing
it on Annie
ya know cuz you right so this is what
I'm talking about you two blue chipper
you are the everyman you you lead the
pack right so I want to know from your
perspective how did it flow for you I
told you it was the power port
extraordinaire it was the loading
simulator this game ran horribly like
and then then people reacted like I'm
lying about this stuff they didn't run
like that I'd be like what game is you
play cuz it wasn't so what I played
did you like how you run around flying
in the air with the what's those advert
or what they call those those tablets
but they call them back not even knowing
the name fraud alert but you need to
light that red one for that that's a
good game it's gonna have this place
people are gonna love it it's not for me
okay so why is it not for you I'll break
it down why I don't like the way they do
in the end game like oh but the stuff I
have issues with it isn't that is in the
beta so can I do I really bring that up
like no I mean you could touch it we
gotta touch on
I guess the King's topic is you know
anthems beta I mean there is a
demographic of people that like playing
games for long about the times sometimes
I do think that the division destiny
anthem all these games Diablo they go
after this amount of people I think that
anthem in Diablo or in a corner and
right now you know up and told that the
division to the division wasn't even in
in a corner it was just sitting there
eating its Doritos I hit looking around
watching everyone else have fun but uh
you know dust and now you know the
division 2 and destiny are in its own
quarter it's like this is how we're
doing things this is our standard we
have this endgame content and we rock
you and you're over anthem it's like
we're just gonna make our stuff more
bullet sponges we're gonna make everyone
have more health we're gonna have them
do more damage and you're just going to
do this three different versions of
Grand Master and that's their in-game
sounds at age six he says vision to is
gonna destroy anthem taser light he said
Division two sealed anthems fat your day
going in but collision it's actually a
better game like and it you guys know me
did I have I ever really said anything
positive about the dude like we've been
to
one haters like you know what it was
they gave me the stuff that I wanted
they listened to the feedback I don't
know what it's like Bioware didn't even
look what was going on for five years
what about the argument that they're not
trying to make be and even in that same
Lane like they're doing a Diablo PvE
focus with a what if this is hot
narrative story like you still not what
you're telling me is Division two has a
lane going up and anthem got a lane
going down you for you you personally
don't appreciate the fact that it's just
PvE focused obviously we know how you
feel about rage you have a great new
video out right now and uh you know
breaking this down so that to me it's
just not for you but as far as the game
it that's compared like that what the
subject data versus demo for you know my
comeback for that would be it might not
be for me but apparently with the
feedback that Ubisoft got with the
division it wasn't for a lot of people
because they put everything that I want
in the division - that wasn't in
division right so if it makes an entire
a multi-million dollar corporation been
do they need they bent the knee and they
did what everyone wanted - I think
there's a trend there like and the
people like it's Diablo Diablo hasn't
been around in ten years like it's shown
it I mean Ubisoft is showing with all
their other games man look look how they
retooled Rainbow six they've done with
for honor a game that a lot of us
thought was dead and its tracks alive
and well this is the mo now if they put
out this letter again yeah they're
really they're really good at it I have
a whole division that's okay this game's
gonna come out and it's gonna be hot
garbage
they're like we need you you you hire 20
hire 20 hire 20 go out there get
feedback fix this game I didn't play the
anthem the demo I you know I can I can't
speak to anything of the issues you guys
had but from what I heard it wasn't
great but I mean playing is division
demo this division beta dude it's like
the perfect sequel they took literally
everything that people had a beef with
and to be fair they've been working on
for a long time because they kept
working on the
they kept improving division-one the
dark zone and last up all that stuff
they've fixed and it's just the people
had moved on but they fixed it all along
and everything that they fixed is now
just jumped to Division two then I'm
making a mistake your destiny to one
destined to came out they tried to fix
things and weren't broken mmm my logical
step and yes any two they told you to
leave your stuff behind right and in
Division is not leave your stuff behind
it's everything that the Division one
did at the end of a content is carrying
over to Division two with greater
content about the division that I have
to really put a light on a Bungie over I
have a huge issue a bunch is trying to
resell you stuff that they sold you in
destiny one they've been doing it the
entire destiny to live side but but you
know the division they're like we're not
gonna make you you know where I can use
those as highlights for future DLC which
are all not just relaunch through the
last one what exotics that division got
that they can even big about bring them
but they don't have any why did it take
so why did they ended up Bri bringing
back the the custom games in the
forsaken the custom games what you mean
custom games a destiny okay what I got
to do with this that's what I was saying
is they keep bringing back stuff from
destined you want to resell you and
those many people want it people buying
it clearly right that's what I'm saying
I don't say we can't compare that
specifically the vision division doesn't
have those kind of iconic features to
bring back that's all I'm saying
destiny out of this please there's an
interim provision continue you know
break it off plus key like Atticus in is
at that period of time the only thing
that division was compared to was
destiny and going up against destiny and
I remember when for honor came out attic
was playing for honor at the same time I
was
to get him to play Division one and he
stayed on that and he did his thing on
that and I tried to for honor both of
these games were to most of the people
were in the bushes and they crawled out
of the bushes to get an established base
for honor just lost launched some
content not too long ago and I think
they got some other content coming and
Division two came back with a vengeance
like when they started when they show
you the endgame what everybody was
complaining about before that they
didn't have any in this is the
difference between that battle beta
versus the demo Division two allows you
to touch the endgame right now you can
actually go in there and touch it that
dark zone is available to touch it
certain things is it sectioned off and
made just for performance purposes you
understand like with anthem they say
well what we're giving you is not gonna
be indicative of the final game are you
giving me this
eat a sample your where's where this is
not what I'm taking home when I decide
to buy yeah you purchasing something in
false pretenses because when I get it
home it may not be the donkey that I
like they read it's how some of the
mechanics working anthem for the final
game now yeah there's no people raging
about it on Twitter not giddy I mean but
I want to say something that guy I've
met you I want to shed some light
sometimes I think we as gave us be too
hard though like it's hard to please
gamers man you like if you put a demo
tape now you put a mixtape out saw like
doing so yeah I probably go at the end
of the day of always that if you make a
good game people are gonna praise you
yeah it's so hard to I think to please
us though I mean let's be real like
we've been that we've seen it all and a
lot of gamers are just like yo if you
have any type of for your situation I'll
be jumping I mean the thing is you know
what the positives
you know kingston you know look
were division - it worked yeah I was
able to jump in your say at launch you
know the lack of the loading screens
base to open worlds beautiful seamless
co-op the for no Emily I'm gonna get to
the negatives i'ma get to the negative
definitely you know 4k HDR is beautiful
the TC streets they why they dense they
feel living they got these great random
MPC events the field of view the huge
distances you know this is the game
itself back who the hell play the Lucas
shooter picks up a gun you can't use it
so you get you a behind back to the
house and then you can try it out in the
bushes and no game is garbage every say
the game you can't do the habló things
the division vs. anthem anthem it's in
the bushes I'd rather eat rocks
I'm with the lava care front Adam is
doing stuff that both that's the end
what you call ain't door cool you can
fly like iron
it's a game out there called Ace Combat
you can fly they do well I see that
Friday like yeah hey yeah what they do
well the enemies disappear what is it
bad job with those grenades latest dope
i'ma tell you right now I was nothing
like what they show they Frogner Lordan
out here they still got that team based
combat they still got like I said the
combos every every class is different so
ok it's a team base I'm glad you said
that
yeah you walk right into my trap the
trap up before the contract I set it up
so nice because what you put on it to
lure em in a protein shake
let's see to your fire team members we
decide that room mm-hmm
and yeah got to progress to the next
part what happens with that other dude
you got to sit there and wait for him to
show up right mm-hmm
you can't go any further if I'm holding
you back that's it so it is not like any
other game your right is broken in one
of the games I showed you this is how
you actually playing a destiny and a
duel could be someplace on the other
part of the map someplace else unless
y'all go to space that do can go
wherever the hell he want to go in this
game
y'all are waiting for the other due to
catch up and you're sick now I'm seeing
people oh come on just go to the bottom
we're inside the dark cave I can't find
it where are you on the map come get you
and you have one guy that gotta come out
he got a load back out of the room to go
get the guy who's actually because I was
already regards doing stuff that other
people just don't do because they were
it's like all the good stuff from its
competition and it's like well you're
all the okay so it comes with a really
good inking content they're like yo it's
like Calvin Calvin came in they were
like you know these raids over your
heart man yeah but you know people love
this game called Diablo that came out
ten years ago let's do it that way you
to see what you got to see what you put
in that book back 20 minutes ago let's
turn the game on top his head
let's put loading screens nobody goes
what it is it is Loki EA got that you
know that statistic report back saying
people they don't you know they don't
have time to get on my phone so that
list with a bunch of loading screens to
help them out people love coffee breaks
we still have our narrative they got the
unique again unique styles no other
games doing that I'm telling you stop
running with that narrative nobody is
doing it cuz it's not it doesn't work
it's not good it's not like they can't
do it destiny could put loading screens
everywhere if they they understood that
for it to be fun you have to be playing
everybody Joao I'm trying to go five
I wouldn't know why I can't see my loo I
get what you're saying
I know way out you don't have no issues
with it my only issues obviously the
loading screens definitely bad Diablos
not for everyone and the issue I got at
the end of the day the main issue I got
and I think like I said you got a watch
addicts video is my issue with them is
this the raising the difficulty to me
like that torment type level stuff in
their stronghold is just making
everything more bulletspongy now people
can say oh well division does the same
thing but division actually has
mechanics this year like if you look at
that in-game faction realize that didn't
work but Oh anyway like I say like so I
get it but like besides they gotta have
mechanics and right now I don't know if
the end game loop is gonna die like that
know about the loop till you get home so
you actually did something got home open
the bag
it was nothing inside but it's the worst
Centocor imagine imagine like there are
a whole mission thinking you just got
some hot stuff you got a you got a Duke
okay it's like what it will make you
wonder if you have to beat the mission
or you could just go back without
beating the mission and I agree cop you
know I don't want more sponge no more
sponge people say hash tag not my loot
yeah I like that I like that I gotta
take this
Chad stop might stop doing it I got a
copy and paste something okay
they keep updating the chat okay that's
what I'm concerned about
that's anthem her anthem had no like no
one else had
because we're not gonna die or hurt what
you knew this so we don't know talk
about this land is ridiculous
shout out Lord solve what is going on
with the PlayStation 5 sir
so yeah I know we hardly have any
PlayStation news lately um so in a read
on an a recent reddit post there's been
a patent leak for the PlayStation 5 we
don't know how true it is or not but the
patent leaked apparently seems to
indicate that the PS 5 is aiming for
backwards compatibility and not just
backwards compatibility for ps4 but
across the entire spectrum patient
titles so and from what I can glean from
a little bit that they talked about the
specifics of the patent
um it's it plans to do it in much the
same way that the Xbox does it with the
Xbox one basically spoofing processors
and convincing the current hardware that
it's actually running old hardware so
it's interesting that they they that's
kind of the only way it could be done
especially when you look at ps3 with how
difficult that has been to emulate um so
I won't know what you guys think about
this because for me you know I'm I'm
happy it's about time it's you know I
all this talk about oh you know that we
don't want this all the fighting back
and forth between fanboys on both sides
of the argument I'm like you know what
if if you're a PS PlayStation fan and
you were not for some sort of backwards
compatibility you're not a fan to me to
me you're you just like the beef you
just like to fight with the Xbox heads
but for me these things back compat has
always been about legacy mm-hmm putting
your being able to have your legacy in
one place and being and then being able
to control the legacy right the the the
narrative around their games and stuff
like that I think that's what Xbox is
doing I think that's what Nintendo is
kind of starting to do and I think
that's a PlayStation should do you again
they want you to buy the game 40 times
over everything you know what's funny it
is but at least you know what it is
there
olena narrative is their legacy who else
is doing it with them right I'm not
saying is right or wrong I'm just saying
who else is who else is controlling
Nintendo's paper Nintendo I'm not doing
it hashtag not my Nintendo Wow that
could place these we knew they were
gonna copy
we knew this will cut up to this wait
wait wait nope I got where's my fraud
yeah hello early you popped early and
look at you now know when you hit the
icon on your PlayStation to do back
impact there's gonna be 29.95 so any
really gonna be no real bad compare they
go show you a way how they can sell you
PlayStation now all over again it's a
good position now all over again
alright at that time this could be
called playstation then playstation
later so don't don't listen they already
have bad compat in a purchasing form
it's not gonna be free like how you know
Microsoft sent yo you know just you got
it you had a game to store it up in
there Boom Bang isn't that's not how
it's gonna go down it's gonna be in a
fashion that you will have to pay you
would have to pay to play what sources
do you have that Sony has never done
anything for y'all for free so don't
ever think you've always paid for that
is no always I'm cursed
you're saying just so I clarify this
argument through the history of Sony has
never done anything for free history
that's right so when the roulette you
saw almost every generation they've let
you play previous generations that never
happened
oh you know what it is you're gonna sit
this all right they took that from me I
brought that PlayStation ok I brought
that PlayStation that was able to do
that or where they were they've had it
dude what happened a totally came five
seconds later who brought the next
PlayStation that couldn't do the back
compare mm-hmm he tried he tried to
throw the disc inside you know they said
go find I did that there PlayStation
that we discontinued tryna for me girl
I'm not into that forming y'all don't
play that compared you go do exactly
what I said you're gonna like it you're
like the only reason that I do kind of
feel like that you know they might not
go that direction
well first off people say back in fact
if we've seen anything it's not as easy
as just turning on a switch
every time Microsoft they have to
literally get permission from publishers
to put it back on the system they can't
just openly you know do it on their own
will I don't know there's good there's
reasons that there's certain games
that's still not on backing pad there's
reasons it took so long it took how long
for Call of Duty's because they didn't
want to drop the big Call of Duty's when
all this all the bad ones were going on
so they waited for a while I don't I do
think they're gonna backwards
compatibility there's no way they don't
because it stays in delight he said that
the architecture was exotic yeah yeah
they always do it all exotic Oh like
what happens to that when that exotic MS
now your feet oh it was so exotic that
the next system couldn't do the last
system systems later to get the first on
the pit for PSX that's gonna be the same
architects three and on the PSX you can
play ps3 games free to the pre s7 you
could only play ps1 a ps4 games
what's the PS eight can play all of them
let's be clear so this joint is a patent
right this is a
is a patent doesn't necessarily mean end
of the day we got it I want to shout out
what about for a good friends to the
realm short Lord John liniment from
digital foundry he also confirms he was
actually going at it with a some Xbox
fans in reference today's so on look
there's no way
Sony leaves one of the most dominant
software runs of the generation with ps4
off the table like to me I'm curious
about the patent or in this regard King
like they talk about backward
compatibility from ps1 to ps4 likely we
get that together on a plug-and-play
that they put out right so the key comes
down to fertile I think that would be
late let's be real like they have all
that library we create if they can do it
if that's true it's the question okay
yeah exactly because the is my thing is
and I want to ask solving kidneys if
that's the kid what happens the guy kind
PS now because I don't see them walking
away fine and we all know memo we had
j'w shot the cradles we had him on when
the numbers financial numbers came out
and PS now is actually proving to be so
I can't see them walking away from them
I personally think that PS now is gonna
carry over to PS 5 and that's gonna be
their backwards compatibility they're
gonna say okay you want to play oh
there's $20 a month
that's a ping is sayin singing that it's
supposed to be on a hardware level right
so break well the thing about it what
they might be doing to make the PS now
run better with the PS this is C
everybody's losing this right when you
were getting over to your Xbox one you
knew that James is carrying over from
your 360 all right so you kept your dis
mmm right you kept those games and
hoping that this is the month that your
game that you got that you paid $60 for
back in the days
becomes a backward compatible and know
when it did you put it in and it ran
better use like oh my god this is
amazing
how many people still got PlayStation 2
games without having a PlayStation 2 Oh
PlayStation 3's guy that's about all
Susie is right
King mention something specific that
specific to the Xbox in particular the X
is the improvements to the games on the
X and even yes like there's no
indication here that this is going to do
that this is just straight up you can
play them right here here's the thing
you're completely right sob and I'm glad
you brought there's a good point because
the key with how X out to build still
well shout to those - man on the owner
on the backpack team the thing the
difference is these guys added Xbox one
X enhancements 4k almost they were in
essential remasters once right so the
key is how is playstation gonna handle
is this is gonna be a straight one to
one because from what we see based on
this rumor in this pattern is based
they're trying to mimic the behavior of
previous consoles using multiple
processors so it's gonna trick psy is
gonna trick the software into running it
on its original part essentially the
same system just with a little caveat
there read the architecture was so
different that's why they weren't able
to do from ps3 deponent or so easy now
px5 I apparently this is your boy mark
Cerny kids right well they apparently
this is what the patent is most mister
twelve teraflops that I've just said
from ps1 death actually if you split it
down a half in a single quarry actually
uh twelve teraflops right now I can show
you so Betty but it's to be true it
would be great I would just be happy
honestly with ps4 backward compatibility
just cuz no are we gonna have a bimini
if they come out backwards compatibility
this is this is 98 I want you to see
this right because I'll put this to
challenge to anybody that's on this
panel right now you want your knees back
this is how you can get your knees back
so practically I won the list bet you
won the spider-man Baio there wasn't any
me go beat mommy is this that's only
ain't doing it for free so they are
doing it but it would be in wrong way
shape or form
not even like having the
let me talk about this so you're saying
it's not hardware-based nuttin you can't
put your old disc in and none of that no
you go put it in let's say nine ninety
five make you buy the game you already
got again because they just say listen
right now we having problems with the
chicken in the same I think this is
mainly gonna be an us versus you thing I
don't know I think I go front we've been
known so times they're not eating of
course they ain't eatin of course listen
these stocks just did it dip you know
what you know what I can't I can't
believe they're gonna charge you for a
game you own all right Paige okay guess
what I'm on King side we go grow up or
shut up versus you I don't know if I
could take that little bit right now
they ideas the dues that if there's
anybody in the game that can do it it
will do it that you will push it this in
and it will say what you own and then
it's described like a second option if
you want the Pro Edition we may have to
retreat sony's been known man but still
that's harsh like that you have to hate
your fan base but but they're playing
anthem so there's a loading screen
before the cage that I'm worried about
reason why I can't take is be good they
Gaikai as an established institution
making money off of streaming and they
but that's the same thing though if they
charge for that King still wins
oh no but the patent the patent says
that they're going to do some time
hardware emulation to trick it like the
right what's gonna happen is it's going
to be built into the PlayStation to help
that service flourish know how so if
markets off is doing it with like data
centers and stuff like that to in Crete
to decrease late I mean Microsoft said
that they were building they were gonna
have some kind of hardware structure to
help to help the X cloud function I
don't know I think you guys just date
he'd been doing it all right they they
have been doing my PS now and PS now
isn't great so how do they battle it yes
now no no it's doing well but the
service isn't great man but I'm talking
hello now huh they allow you to download
the games anything anything that was
made neither because ps2 games - well
whatever any ps2 games they got that
that got upgraded so to speak for the
ps4 yeah you can download as well right
so but if you look at those games if you
look at like I think it was at the gtas
they got sort of remade re-released for
the ps4 it's not great it's not they
have they have them both they're
basically oh oh full screen you see how
I want jewel like the box I want to see
you you want him in a box I'm concern I
don't want him in the box pause I want
his knees on the ground pause all right
oh wow now hold up this quickly I don't
want to hear any PS now stuff this is
specifically to the point that they if
they have some sort of actual hardware
back compat that you can't put your game
in and play for free look at still a
[ __ ] what is the relation this I know
the simulation is that they charge in
any way no if they charge you put the
how's that - how is that [ __ ] are you
in any form when you put your old game
in their skin if you put your spider-man
in if you hit the like the cancel button
in the $4.99 be dismissed the disc and
then the screen pops up this is you have
to go to your local game if all this is
is if PlayStation 5 comes out and there
is backward compatibility if there if
you put your disc in or you try to
access it just on a monetary level if
there's a cost that's the Benham e
what's the specific revenue I think if
there is a cost to it
hmm I been Denis on any level on any
level with Hardware back compat and it
is PS there's no Hardware back compared
with back and then you want me to take a
bet buy on a service they have already
he'll know about Hardware back compact
with a disc that is sovereign all right
you saying this patent is gonna come to
fruition my joint is saying they did
just covering bases exactly so am I
we're doing a team for doing that -
they're not doing that - okay so let's
if there is hardware back compatibility
I'm down with these knees and a you
ain't got a pate and there's gonna be in
the digits gonna be in a box if there is
Hardware back compatibility mong-koo
involve PS now now got you I mean so
wait wait wait I'm confused saw breaking
there so if there's Hardware back come
back you put a disk in the PS 5 then for
them yes five four games for free
sovereign whence if you can't demons
what if there's no hardware back
comparable then there's no bet if they
don't do it then they're not doing it if
they don't but I'm not I'm not arguing
whether they do it or not your whole
point of this is that there will be
there my whole point of it specifically
brought up the money issue and I sent it
I don't believe that if it's happening I
don't believe that I'm telling you I
don't believe it is if there is hard
weather they don't even box alright this
is what yeah yeah yeah clear on your
terms with
one part of the bet is whether they have
it in that period right now other part
is if they do have it then it's true
there's gonna be a charge
okay so we got it I heard of him earth
Bethany has returned for 2019 in the
buildings coming I'm getting one of the
Me's will have lotion dirty down three
what is going on sir so they have a beta
all right but the beta has the wrecking
zone why is he whispering this okay I'm
sorry
they have a beta the beta has wrecking
zone and anyone here played that no I
think you'll hear seen gameplay of it oh
yeah yes what's the thoughts is it is it
is the iron Lords of Peru nor is it not
iron love the crazy dude everyone
besides King David I love the crazy
decision they had with the fake
enthusiasm bringing a game like yo his
bag I don't know down I don't know what
bag they gave him but he was buying a
car after that because he was that damn
happy and that it wasn't all that but it
did what they say full duty I think it's
gonna be fine but if we gonna call a
spade a spade we're just talking about
how anthem didn't look Howard some honey
or let's go like a bull demo four years
ago looks nothing like that okay so
first that was a tech demo that was more
playable okay
um that way ever come out openly say
that's gonna represent the fun no no but
what I'm gonna do with Sully services to
Microsoft when they did that successful
right when you throw that behind closed
doors not
my games come first but it was like
let's put that out there and give these
things these dudes remember the matric
era that's for me right so you know oh
boy
was on one we saw it ooh it's fine do
not tell me that this game doesn't look
better as far as all the lighting is
moving up right now he said y'all
apologists for this game no I'm not I
apologize for the game first of all his
own game pass so I'm gonna be playing a
game for freaking a game pass a game now
that wasn't enough that happen I'm glad
you said that
let's get to that here's the thing and
I've seen this narrative going on right
now honestly I'm not coming for you I'm
just honestly asking you and the rest of
us on the panel like when we see or
mediocre to average game that gets and
now I say the crackdown is I'm just
saying in the past I am now start gay as
a Dowson game pass is it an excuse or a
cop-out if the game is on game pad to
say well it's a game fast game anyway so
excusing them for the level of quality
that is they've never ever thought that
crackdown was an a.1 game you know why
he never thought it was an a.1 game but
when it first came out it came with the
halo demo yes
all right so it pushed the game into a
top-tier level that game was never top
tier game that's some beat class game
that they had in the bushes okay how do
you have the argument that then all
these years later you couldn't try to
make it that that's what what about the
time and any what's the width in his
thinking they took the time they delayed
this game multiple time saying that the
level of quality was not up to snuff
here we are and at the end of the day
they just needed to get it to feel like
crackdown so all that time it just
didn't feel like crackdown that was it
wasn't that it was
it was this it was it was done these
problems Don this is Donnie's oh man oh
man so just hold up I'm just clarifying
for the viewers you're blaming this all
on dawn yeah chicken now different on
Phil Phil did Phil saw the reception
that the game got and said you'll put it
back in the cooker
that's that gauge to something that's
was respectable so I can put it out so I
could put my name on this right now live
or die Phil's gonna have to own this one
right Phil's gonna have to own this one
but it's not scalebound it's not
cancelled sure so all you guys out there
talking about oh you know this game
alright fine I'll buy it they can't if
you go out there try the game and then
talk about it later
what game pass so if you don't have game
pass that show their problem and if you
don't feel like buying a game don't buy
the game just like a billion of the
games like Anthem I'm not buying I saw
somebody's in the Seine and I'm buying
I'm not buying it unless you gifted me
that game I'm not buying it and I'm
gonna tell you this you say oh Anthony
way better than crap I'll crack now but
guess who's playing crack now they would
this kid is you know why because
intership and it's not so and I load
this I don't got no loading screens
useful to be having fun just clarifying
argument to justify having fun Odin
screen so the way that you're hating on
this game I would expect if let's say
anthem shows up in that EA access vote
is it a cop then no so so why would you
but but you call me this creaking so
it's okay for me to get free something I
know I'm paying for it it's not really
free I'm paying for anything
falling is my copy but the Adrienne Bora
of gaming you can say whatever you want
Jonathan beat Zumba anthem you're gonna
have a same face you're gonna have the
Jordan mean face and then when you sell
it back I just want you to shout me out
when you send it back the Micra so buy
it digitally so they can just give it
back so you don't have to worry about
holding that dead body in your yourself
deaf Sega say oh I guess I would be
patriotic to make King play ever with me
did I want to say this last part on
crack then what about the whole Ryan
McCaffrey situation because we know they
dropped it you know they had the I
Giancana first on the multi-player him
and that's llegará shouting those two
and they they were I would say they like
ripped it ripped it but they were
definitely not that it's an average game
they like he said multiple times I enjoy
the game but it's nothing outstanding
right and then he said you know he made
quotes like it's like a science project
you know of all these different things
he felt the destruction was not
impressive at all it didn't have any
weight he said it felt like styrofoam
and stuff to bring the like the locking
system he had issues with that so you
know what are you saying cuz right now
it is a big thing going on in the
community we know IGN's been in the
crossfire a lot lately
so like what do you say as far as you
know is i GN being too hard on the game
or maybe a bias some people say they're
not giving it a chance
only thing I have to say to ride the
Caffrey it's a game fair to me they beat
they're being honest about the game
especially like when I talk about the
game was played daesil McGarry I played
that game it's not the same
can we all be running who were here
expected like an eight nine out of ten
character nobody nobody but a lot of
people trying to put a metric to it we
have a lot of people are talking about
Microsoft Games average of metric of 65
to 70 right so in that sense I can hear
y'all
talking right but when you guys get a
hundred games for $10 well inside game
paths or whatever service that you want
to have because game pass is coming to a
system near you understand that part do
you hear what I just said so when you
look up on your Playstation you look up
on your switch and game passes rolling
around and then you can play crack down
to brother mmm - out the de la Pole he
said game past should not be an excuse
for mediocre content it's not an excuse
for mediocre content it's not well don't
act like is I'm not top-flight games and
some sagging pants I mean I mean for
Forza horizon because at the end of the
day if you want it like if you want to
buy this game go buy it if you don't
don't buy it like that's literally as
far as that go you go before you go
attic on Philly Eagle thank you brother
the fire ala super chat mostly we're
talking smack about anthem we playing it
because it's gonna fight you ate a
gamer's game of the year for me shoutout
Philly Eagle Caterpie is gonna speculate
ours right I'm gonna respect your money
because everything that we own but he's
not going to respect your opinion that's
about to come out I will say this right
i'ma say this Philly after your 50th
loading screen hey you gotta figure out
when you get back that I'll see you know
when you gonna be talking with your
friends in the headset hey Blake what
you got what you got what did the boss
drop for you well let's get back to the
house when you get sick or tired of it
let me know and let me know we're still
your game of the year in the middle of
the year he respects every was a big man
shoutout to that yeah that's all I got I
mean I'm waiting everybody else I mean
when it drops when it drops I'm gonna
have fun collecting orbs like and gettin
brolic like I did in the first game that
that's my favorite part of that game was
so I'm gonna be doing that and I'm gonna
be playing man going back and forth
between that and Metro on the same I'm
good like ah you know whatever listen
you know it is what it is it looks I
need to play I don't
I still need to play it before I go and
I'm gonna get in the technical test demo
after the podcast it actually starts
now what the if you're part of the Xbox
inside program you get to get part of
the technical test of crackdown it's
going on right now oh I can see you
playing possibly right now your PC guy
you know play anywhere so I really want
tested I would see what it is but yeah
maybe honestly an issue you know reports
look kind of mediocre so you know it's
one of those things yes it's in-game
pass I'm not excusing that it's in-game
pass that it needs to not be quality I'm
not gonna say that but I'm willing to
give it a shot shot the Aaron's game and
a couple people they stay in
legitimately having fun with it so it's
one of those things until I play it I
can't really comment too much but I
don't want i GN to be getting all this
work if they don't like it and just
being that they're bad journalists if
they didn't like it if it's happy I
don't understand like one minute this
chills and one minute they're you know
they're getting ripped for actually
having an opinion on what I would like
to know is that they really enjoyed the
other ones
listen McAfee's always said that he
liked crackdown one he's always said
that everybody always this is the BS
that goes with that right there we all
love crackdown one you know to was a
problem why when you actually I did a
coma something with a beta again in
there right they've always shipped it
with something you know why because
can't stand up its meaning all that was
actually that big strong input terry
crews on again that's the problem
yeah he was just going to
released it didn't have no super
celebrity sponsor and doors
it wasn't trying to make noise is making
noise with no substance now hopefully
the the multiplayer has some substance
to it I'm so full destructibility I
don't hear if they say it felt like
paper mache I'll give a damn great set
full destructibility is doing Phil
destructibility they did not say oh
they'll be full destructibility and it's
gonna have a gravitas to it no they
scrape full destructibility they say
paper mache but is there anything is
when you look at old games that have had
full destructibility in there like Red
Faction like this there's been crazy
full destructibility years ago but
bright alan did you do multiplayer and
in in red fracture no no okay
battlefield 4 I had the one with the big
building it was a canned of it though
yeah blast into the wall and are they
actually battlefield and in crackdown
actually have a lot in common when it
comes the destructibility it feels like
everything's destructible by like the
foundation like the pose the whole
buildings up yeah right I can't I can't
wait to touch it
I can't wait my spiel on it so I think
gonna be a Spider Man game that John
were to me but Phil didn't let it die
and Phil sat behind it and let it come
forward you know in situation yeah it
was disappointing to me and I've said
this about crackdown from the jump is
just that they could have done so much
more like the powers and stuff like that
I fully said I've seen of the campaign
seems like they've expanded on that
stuff a little bit like I see like you
driving up the sides of buildings of the
car now and crazy stuff so I hope they
did that because for me like yeah it's
never been that Tier one game and but in
the Indian attack from the the first
game to now they could have done a lot
to expand on that formula and it just
quickly they did it okay enough
I know attic you out of here right
coming through I'll see you guys next
week I'm gonna draw it's gotta be clear
addict you with me with sovereign and
his knees yeah
I'll get one of his knees and you get
the other one me out here was just the
g1 display the meas together things that
it will fit as we do these rabbit take
cider you gotta go so wrap it takes
rapid round team will take because
there's a lot of news this week so on
Xbox Live to switch briefly will talk
about that and then arm some sad news
Activision / Blizzard employee lay off
so our let's start with Lord saw what do
you feel is going on as far as the Xbox
5 to switch how do you feel about that
and then also about the the layoffs
that's going on I think I mean the Xbox
Live - switches is the beginnings of
what Xbox wants to do right sort of be
everywhere and you know obviously that
doesn't mean that you're gonna be seeing
Xbox games on switch and Android and
stuff anytime soon in that form but I
think the fact that the under guts of
Xbox Live the chat stuff just the
infrastructure stuff being on other
platforms it is huge and it's the
beginnings of how they're going to start
pushing X cloud on everything and stuff
like that so it's it's me it's it's a
big deal it's a big deal it's it's not
you know we're you know halo is gonna be
on the switch but it's it's the
beginnings of going down that road ok
and what about the Activision Blizzard
situation so you guys got a go-to King
first because I haven't really looked at
the details of that so is this
speculation or this stuff that's
happening it's happening it's happening
apparently yeah Jason Schreyer they said
that the employees that ready for brace
themselves from massive layoffs could
lose their jobs are on Tuesday
potentially hundreds of employees so um
well again if we go back to what we've
talking about and talked about last
couple of weeks about Activision
Blizzard it just feels like that was a
marriage that was always destined to
fail because their approach to making
games are so vastly different that those
ideologies were always going to clash
and at some point if bliss if the
ideology of Blizzard didn't fall in line
with Activision wanting to make money
hand over fist on everything something
was going to give
and I think we're at that point I think
you know if you look at the narrative
with ei and all these other companies
that they're about products that are
replayable people can come back to and
and make money for them on a daily basis
and that was always going to be an issue
so it's that it's really sad if that's
what that's the beginnings of the
crumbling of this although I I hope
Blizzard on its own
that's a again it's not gonna be on its
own but I hope this kind of opens the
door to maybe a divorce but it's sad for
all those peoples in their jobs it's
it's really ridiculous it is when it
definitely is let's get King on King uh
your favorite console the Nintendo
switch get it box live that the Xbox
Live was gonna get this behind on their
joint open the door hey shorty highlight
you a taste for second you know so
actually feel them put that foot the
duck I you know what's next gamepad just
sitting there talking billing it but
them games will be on this soon all
right see that yeah the old Activision
Blizzard delay a little bit I think I'm
gonna take all the jokes out of it
because um people losing their jobs and
his climate is not funny mm-hm but in a
lie denotes you got rare hiring up to
200 people for their development team
well so it's it's the ying-yang is the
balance of it we already knew that those
companies didn't mesh it wasn't gonna be
a good marriage um it seems like that
what a lot with Activision they don't
take an account of the development teams
that they're purchasing and seeing if
it's a good fit with them they Chuck
shoehorn them in and after a period of
time it just doesn't work and it's I'm
happy that Bungie is at a point where
they can stand alone and separate from
that marriage with warts might say
because you know when you separate from
a situation you have to
Lu's employees because of something
that's not therefore because they
started working at a company and their
company got purchased by another company
and that didn't work out and now they
are unemployed they do have skills they
do have trades the industry as well
so hopefully they can be picked up by
the next round of systems um needing
development staff and and to be fair I
think the industry does a really good
job of banding together when stuff like
this happens and trying to get people
jobs yeah yeah I mean I'm with you guys
I'll jump on that chopper sisters will
keep it to transition with the blizzard
thing yeah it said I mean obviously you
know I'm saying I mean I I can't see
Activision's books or anything like that
but I can I can't say we're sure you
know that the CEO getting that crazy
bonus is a direct correlation but
regardless of what it just it just don't
feel like a good look you know saying
with the climate what's going on at the
top but a food chain over there and the
bottom and like you said you know sob
you just hope that these guys can check
bounced on your feet I know immediately
after the Bungie exit and divorce
there's ton of people that were in you
know Activision that their whole job was
to work on the PC side and they so they
kind of knew something was coming up on
their end you know I mean and now you
have even more stuff going on so that
type of stuff you never want to see
shout out to those dudes I mean I
definitely hope they land on your feet
as far as the switch stuff man you boy
cog put you on first I had an article
shot too dizzy so I play back gaming
down net you know switches be very open
to long new SDKs I think vivix was the
first they allowed in text messaging and
I believe fortnight was the first to
kind of utilize the improve Lord King
and it can be can't be not I'm not
downing the switch see a lot of think
that I hate on the switch out of hate
no remember a lot of those amiibos that
purchased because I was playing Zelda
well what I asked for is original new
content is what I asked for
don't give me a Smash Brothers there's a
remix of the other smash but I don't
want a comparison of a Wii U game to a
new game just just stop put out new
content and if it's good content I'm
going to purchase I don't know what
oh crap where mmm that's not yeah you
know at the end of the day I love this
stuff because we all do the Achilles
heel was that infrastructure and to see
you know Phil and I'm push this
initiative
you know what Xbox Live I mean I think
that's fantastic
I want to see how the Xbox SDK is gonna
be implemented you know will the games
me fully cross playing you know your
achievement list like I want a situation
where if it's a cross play game that's
over there like I can can either
continue where I left off or I can still
do you know the progress the
achievements you know that with me late
I won't wanted that across safe cross
play man and you can do that fills our
games and I just can't wait to the day
that when you can get a good Xbox Live
experience on that PlayStation with the
headset and you talk to the poll and
everything is really going on really
well and there's no dropouts and stuff
like that I can't wait so Phil slide up
in nozbe m's I don't think so I think I
don't think so he's ready for that would
be they would need confirmation from
Microsoft that they getting out of the
hardware business that that's the only
way they would do that they might be you
never know what happens later baby
we'll see so I'm shouted um you know I
want to see how this thing you know get
the fruition but that's all I got on I
appear a bit quickness let's get out of
here
Oh new IOP poll for the week with the
surprise reveal and tremendous success
of Apex legends for respawn and
Electronic Arts which EA franchise do
you feel has the most to lose now based
on this release the choices are a Anthem
apex release date is too close and can
affect momentum B battlefield 5
firestorm who's gonna buy this battle
royale DLC map see Titan full speed
I don't care that is finally thrown into
bushes when he goes up on Twitter to
morrow
Lords of the realm Lord I got to go but
Lord saw where can the five people find
you with um what's there yeah this week
man guys go out there and bellies games
man Friday is a big gaming day man we
got we have crackdown we have Metro
Exodus and we have that early access to
anthem so go out and play the games you
want to play and that's it don't let
anybody tell you otherwise go out there
and play your games okay you catch me
your Twitter Lord saw IO p and b ik
solving on PSN xbox live and real quick
a big shout-out to that one person who
always comes in at the start of the show
and downvotes us cuz I got a respect
your game I mean he's loyal with it like
he comes in he makes sure every single
week you know why he said he because we
know exactly who I love I love everybody
man I respect the fact that you take the
time to get here 1 p.m. and download us
I appreciate that respect
I respect your click game D or the polio
day savage or full a that's crazy
Lloyd King the premium gala is pre me
experience today
what kind of fire people find you not
going in all right well um alright this
is the first this is the first podcast
I'm gonna get off and I'm not gonna run
upstairs to my best friend so Benjamin
Johnson um so this is a hoping that the
podcast wouldn't in be honest with you
um but uh you can find me as you as you
can see the table is set up right there
table to set up right there and that's
where King the statute is gonna be the
turntables is gonna be there I'm
actually will have a black cloth on it
it's gonna be done up with the white
gloves you understand
are we doing mr. Major Nelson a feel for
certain statues you gotta have them
white gloves oh you know you got to
really give that whole Vanna White feel
gonna bring it all in I have over 40 new
statues and we're gonna go over the 30
statues that I do have that you actually
can't see we're gonna go over those in
depth and when they came out the scale
size and I'm gonna tell you why not to
buy these display cases and why to buy
these display cases and then we're gonna
get a room tour after we go through all
the statues and on that channel we're
gonna talk about customs because there's
a lot of places that you can custom
statues a lot of statues are channels
they don't tell you about customs and I
will actually have links in there where
guys you can actually go get these and
Commission them where it's safe with to
place your money and your stuff will
actually show up they will come from
China they will come from different
places but you will get your stuff and
uh you can be happy about your one on
one scale of things um also well arcade
king is coming the the intro was up the
music is up and that you're gonna see
that arcade machine is gonna be right
over here in this area so you know back
there that room back there is my man
cave
we're gonna do your deep dive into the
man cave but guys we got a lot of
content coming that's gonna be at the
the website it's gonna be on YouTube is
we're gonna have links we have Instagram
we have the Facebook we have a whole lot
of things poppin for you guys and also
just like deaf singers say if you want
me to play anthem gift it to me and I'll
beat it oh but I'll definitely play
because we do have patreon things with
patreon members get served first all
right so you get the first buff at mail
at that table you get the first hangout
meal at that table so patreon dude you
were first in line we always respect
your dollar and
I hope that you had a great show today
because I definitely needed you guys
this week job became familiar absolutely
I know you had a rough week and the love
we got the laughs we get to share with
you guys when and definitely helps our
day as well you have no idea of stuff we
go through so salute to the Lords of the
realm in the chat love y'all jokes
everything was fun positive energy love
y'all man was lit yeah man so you
already know what it is you know hit
that like notification yeah I get that
notification gang up then I'm saying and
you already know in the iron law podcast
channel links will be in description
lore carboxyl will have that audio up
know that SoundCloud that YouTube that
Spotify all that good stuff you're also
in the link or discord channel it is
popping please get an escort our discord
is off the chain if you don't at me I
don't hear you so please we're getting
that discord we got a lot we're talking
about like I said if you went to just
specific games or we have the channels
for the games we have channels for
combat 12 we got channels for Marvel DC
Comics I mean people against some really
intense discussions in there so please
check that out that will be in
description as well shout out to the
stream team right now Laurel PD is
streaming right now Devine get in there
laughs you want to see that division too
if you want to fence about it go check
that out and also shout out to the
entire stream team lady l-boogie Lord de
l'opéra who was in a chat today and Jane
is a lost universe there and of course
the old-school-style himself I mean each
week every week on our Lord twitch TV
dot slash iron law podcast and of course
he bounces was in a chat today you
already know um last word number 48 is
up on my destiny
you know I yeah I gotta give a shout-out
to filly eagle he's dug today mm and he
put a super check in today word fax that
is crazy
that means a lot it definitely means a
lot like I said we got that going and
also I saw one in the last word you know
again we talking an ant and we talking
that division that destiny you know
saying and shout-out to y'all giving
positive feedback to the graphic god man
for the photo I was beautiful
yeah gave give me that little shadow
dancer feel in the woods
but that's all I got Lourdes everyone
enjoy your Sunday yes dizzy big things
are coming episode 100 you already know
we gonna keep that long right now just
two more episodes are we gonna have some
fun everybody's got a Sunday
honey our government peace 100